our understanding is that the irish
cabinet has now agreed on that plan
to move the country to level five
restrictions
uh ireland operating a five-tier uh
system so this is moving it to the
maximum set
of restrictions however it is important
to note that there are some key
differences
uh between what will come into effect we
understand from midnight
on wednesday for a period of six weeks
and what we saw
in the initial lockdown back in the
spring uh
for example it is our understanding that
the government intends to keep schools
in ireland
open as well as child care facilities uh
elite sports so like the gaelic football
championships here in ireland
and horse racing will still be able to
take place
and we understand as well that
protections will be put in place
for industries like construction in an
attempt to protect
some of the key economic sectors in
ireland so
it won't be exact an exact replica of
the sort of harsh lockdown that we saw
in march right through to mid-may it is
however
uh very much the maximum set of
restrictions pretty much the irish
government has at its disposal at the
moment
and you have to remember it was only two
weeks ago that the irish government
under mio martin
declined the expert public health advice
to move
to level five tonight that looks like a
serious error in judgment
because just two weeks later with cases
spiraling
new record cases being set four times in
the last week
they are now forced to acquiesce to that
advice and move ireland to level five
with some exceptions as i just mentioned
for a period of six weeks so this will
last right through november
uh up until december the first although
we also understand that there will be a
review
carried out after a four week period so
if the data
uh is promising enough and supported we
could see that uh
lockdown come to a close maybe a bit
earlier than the six week period
the goal clearly is to try and save
christmas here in ireland
for retailers for the hospitality sector
the expectation is that this will
sufficiently constrict
that rising trend in case numbers uh in
time
to not perhaps open up fully the country
but to certainly drop down a couple of
levels
for the christmas period so just to
recap uh level five restrictions with a
few exceptions
things uh for example like keeping the
schools open keeping construction going
will kick in uh from midnight on
wednesday here in ireland
uh that means people will have to stay
at home it means the pubs and
restaurants will be restricted only to
delivery or take away
services people will have to stay within
a distance of their home on
on the pain of being fined by the
guardian the irish police we believe
that will be set
at a five kilometer radius so it does
make ireland somewhat of an outlier in
european terms really you'd have to look
to places like the czech republic in
israel
to find similar uh restrictions at the
moment
it's been met with dismay by
restaurateurs hoteliers publicans
and retailers all non-essential retail
will have to close
as well under this plan so a really
drastic move by the irish government
which as i said just a fortnight ago
rejected this course of action but from
midnight on wednesday ireland will be
going back to
what approaches a full lockdown if not
quite